(classical music)
- Hi, I'm Chelsea, and this is Hadley.
And today, Hadley's going to
a luxury dog while I go to work.
- Mason definitely
deserves a day at the spa.
When he feels good,
everyone else feels good.
- I hope she has a good day.
(gentle music)
- Hi, I'm Cynthia, I'm
owner of New York Dog Nanny.
We offer a variety of services
that you cannot find anywhere else
in this city or probably in the world.
Reiki and therapeutic touch are growing
in popularity with
people, as well as, pets.
(cash register dings)
- She gives me so much
that it's cool to have
this opportunity to let
her just like be pampered.
- Well, he looks like an old, Greek man
'cause he's got very soulful
eyes and a lot of expression.
(cash register dings)
- There are so many reasons
that dogs are good for people.
And that, I hope, people
are good for dogs.
- He helps brighten even the worst days.
He just knows how to be
there when you need him.
(cash register dings)
- She's very in tuned, I think,
with like subtle shifts in emotions.
If I'm sad, she'll follow me around,
and like make sure I'm okay.
They're happy, and have
these like inner lives,
and you get to kind of experience that.
Just like a best friend.
There's a reason they says
it's man's best friend.
'Cause they are.
(gentle music)
(cash register dings)
- Reiki is an Eastern-based
philosophy in meditation.
And what it does is it promotes
deep relaxation in the body,
as well as, boost the immune system.
With the dogs we're working
on specific energy centers
that are gonna help balance
and rejuvenate the animal.
- I would describe Hadley's personality
as a very independent, very sassy.
- He's just a big mush,
he's loves attention.
And he loves being around people.
(gentle music)
(cash register dings)
- My name is Veronica Burke.
And we are going to do a
session of therapeutic touch.
What's going on in my mind,
I'm putting into my hands.
(gentle music)
(Mason snores)
- I love her, and I want her to be happy,
and to feel nice, and in any way
that I can do that for her,
I would want to do that.
- Oh, my goodness.
You're so handsome.
- Hi, Hadley, you look so cute.
Oh, you're fluffy.
- Did you have a fun day at the spa?
Yeah, yeah (chuckles)?
I think dogs kind of bring out
a different side of people.
- It's so cheesy, but like
dogs kind of bring it back
to like what's important in life.
Friendship and companionship
and being there for each other.
I love dogs so much.
(lighthearted music)
(flag squeaks)